public sénat en partenariat avec la ffb
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le secrétaire général de la cfdt est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité laurent
berger bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de public sénat
avec les échos avec radio classique et
avec la fp médias représentés ce soir
par lucile malandain et jean francis
pécresse
bonsoir à vous deux fois les réformes
accro aux limites vous font bien sûr
réagir laurent berger et vous répondrai
au cours de cette émission à trois
grandes questions 1
le big bang de la formation
professionnelle dévoilé aujourd'hui le
gouvernement reprend t-il la main de
quoi vous fâchez vous nous le dira et de
la réforme ou la révolution à la sncf
est ce que vous allez bloquer ou tenter
de bloquer le pays
dans quelques semaines enfin 3 le retour
de la croissance comment répartir les
fruits mais d'abord une toute première
question d'actualité
[Musique]
l'italie ingouvernable on le voit
aujourd'hui au lendemain d'élections
législatives qui voit à triompher les
partis populistes anti système ce choc
électoral pour toute l'europe vous
inquiète-t-il
oui bien sûr il habille maquette à
double titre et il m'inquiète pour ce
que ça veut dire sur la la situation
politique de ce pays qui est un grand
pays européen
et puis ce que ça veut dire pour pour
l'europe inquiétant parce que les
populisme progressent sur finalement des
politiques sociales qui sont mal assumé
sur une politique migratoire qui n'est
pas partagée au niveau européen mais qui
est rejeté par les populations manekine
d'ailleurs je reviens bien sûr parce que
l'europe a laissé d'italie tout seul moi
je me rappelle avoir discuté avec enrico
letta qui expliquait combien il s'était
senti finalement un peu abandonné par
l'europe sur la question migratoire
donc ça m'inquiète parce que les
populismes n'a jamais été une solution
pour les peuples et pour la démocratie
et ça m'inquiète parce que l'italie est
un grand pays européen et que c'est pas
le premier à subir cet assaut de
populisme et donc ça doit nous inquiéter
et ça doit nous alerter aussi sur les
politiques européennes et les politiques
dès ce soir les deux points que vous
évoquez la politique sociale et la
politique migratoire jean-francis ou la
social démocratie
en italie a donc subi un très fort recul
comme en allemagne
et comme en france en 2017 et avec ce
recul au fond est-ce que vous vous
sentez d'une certaine manière remise en
cause parce que dans cette
social-démocratie ya l'idée de ce
compromis social avec des corps
intermédiaires est ce que c'est ce
modèle de société ce modèle de
gouvernance au fond qui est remise en
cause à travers l'europe et donc la
place des syndicats
non parce que si vous prenez l'italie
monsieur renzi lorsqu'il fait ses
politiques économiques lorsqu'il est au
pouvoir c'est politique sociale il le
fait sans s'associer les organisations
syndicales
mes camarades italiens ont été plusieurs
mois avant d'être reçus même par par
matteo renzi donc il n'a pas mis en
place une politique social-démocrate
monsieur renzi il a mené une politique
un peu verticale en pensant que par sa
seule volonté et son dynamisme que je ne
conteste pas il allait pouvoir réformer
un pays difficile à réformer comme celui
des quais l'italie avec beaucoup de
défis économiques et sociaux
non ce que c'est ce que ça dit c'est que
on est dans des sociétés où les tensions
prennent le dessus sur les capacités de
compromis c'est-à-dire que ouzou où la
volonté de repli sur soi la volonté
d'affrontements elle est plus forte que
la volonté de construire en commun est
décalée alors avec cette époque
non je ne vais écrire des égards oui
mais c'est pas nous c'est que je suis
inquiet lorsque on considère qu' il vaut
mieux rejeter l'autre il vaut mieux
affronter à considérer son adversaire au
terme des idées comme un ennemi plutôt
que comme un interlocuteur avec qui il
faut discuter oui je suis inquiet mais
je suis pas décaler parce que par
ailleurs il ya des marges de manoeuvre
ailleurs en europe on le voit ou non par
exemple en allemagne on regarde ce qui
s'est passé en allemagne le week-end est
paradoxal au niveau européen de ce
postulat c'est désagréable avec la
poussée de l'extrême droite un oui mais
où finalement
la volonté démocratique l'emportent
alors que c'est justement vous pensez
que le couple macron merkel est le
dernier rempart en europe et ce que vous
attendez de leur part de porter une voix
forte
voilà et deux événements ce week end la
grande coalition en allemagne qui peut
repartir
et ce dont on vient de parler la poussée
populiste en italie oui si on veut
relancer l'europe
il faut que le couple franco-allemand se
remette en route ils se remettent en
route sur des politiques sociales
assumées au niveau de l'europe des
politiques communes qui nous projette
vers les transitions démocratiques
transition numérique la transition
écologique certes une politique
d'investissement ou minima dans la zone
euro pour pousser l'europe vers le haut
la tirer vers le haut
un gala merkel et à emmanuel macron là
bas je crois qu'au niveau européen a
volé j'étais vous savez j'étais au
sommet social de göteborg et où
j'intervenais au nom des syndicalistes
européens et j'ai vu les chefs d'état
discuter oui je le dis sans ambiguïté on
est plutôt satisfait d'avoir ce
discours-là de niveau français qui se
tient en europe moi j'ai pas d'états
d'âme à le dire non à présent de la
république a plutôt volonté d'avoir une
politique européenne assumée maintenant
ça se mesure à comme toujours aux actes
très bien les actes bien ce sont les
réformes sociales qui sont engagés et
qui peuvent parfois vous fâchez on va le
voir tout de suite c'est donc la
première question de l'épreuve de vérité
consacrée aux grands dossiers sociaux
qui vont nous occuper maintenant
[Musique]
laissez-vous l'uci qui posait cette
première question sociale alors la
ministre du travail mme muriel pénicaud
avait promis un big bang sur la
formation professionnelle le
gouvernement reprend la main sur la
collecte des fonds en les transférant
aux urssaf
est ce que ça vous fâchent est ce que ça
vous satisfait d'abord vous savez moi
nous nous sommes engagés sur la
négociation sera formation pression et
avec un objectif c'est de faire
progresser les droits à la formation
pour les travailleurs
cet objectif il est atteint il est
repris par la ministre c'est plus du
doublement du nombre d'heures du droit à
l'information pour chaque salarié dans
son compte personnel de formation
c'est un droit a crû pour tous les
salariés faiblement qualifiés et
puisqu'ils pourront augmenter leurs
droits à la formation de façon beaucoup
plus importante encore que les autres
salariés
c'est un cpf transition c'est un compte
personnel transition qui pourra être
beaucoup de avec un droit a cru à la
formation
lorsqu'on voudra de reconversion lourde
pendant sa carrière donc il ya tout un
tas de droits nouveaux notamment le
conseil en évolution professionnelle qui
permet d'accompagner les salariés dans
son parcours de formation dont soit
était fait de le choix a été fait
d'abord de reprendre ses droits
je vais pour la ministre non ça veut
dire il ya d'abord la capacité vous
savez moi je cherche pas d'abord les
problèmes
je cherche les solutions et les avancées
pour les travailleurs aidé à ce titre là
oui il y à des avancées que les
partenaires sociaux et la cfdt en
particulier ont négocié et obtenu vous
adresser à vous même en fait non mais je
me satisfais aussi que la ministre
les airs connus dans son dos dans sa
conférence de presse ce matin et dans
son dossier de presse
et ensuite il ya les problèmes de la
gouvernance à moi je vais vous dire très
franchement que le transfert des eaux
caverne urssaf
je sais pas si c'est une bonne solution
mais c'est pas de nature à me fâcher
c'est pas ça ne paraît pas pour moi un
sujet prioritaire ce qui me sujet ce qui
me paraît un sujet prioritaire c'est que
les branches professionnelles que les
partenaires sociaux dans les territoires
puissent définir les besoins en
compétences qui sont nécessaires et pour
ça on aura toujours besoin des opca je
sais pas comment ils s'appelleront
demain peut-être des opérateurs de de
compétences comme j'ai entendu ce matin
donc ça oui je crois que il ya eu un big
bang
si elle aussi on veut reprendre 7 cette
formulation je sais pas c'est un big
bang en tout cas il ya une profonde
transformation de la gouvernance
voilà gouverne la collecte des fonds va
passer un programme jargonner parce que
c'est un peu complexe à défaut la
collecte des fonds c'est pas qu'on soit
très bien qu témoin faire de toutes les
bourses afs est pas allé en partie oui
bien sûr moi ce qui a été annoncé ce
matin
ce qui m'inquiète le plus c'est la
transformation du compte personnel de
formation d'heure en euros en héros
alors c'est vrai qu'on affichage ça fait
pour les salariés 500 euros par an de
forme de droits à la formation c'est
intéressant
ce qui m'inquiète c'est comment ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui on peut prendre
ça sans jargonner on en prend 30
secondes pour expliquer aujourd'hui vous
avez par exemple 20h droit à 20 heures
de formation vous avez besoin de 20
heures pour vous former à telle ou telle
évolution technologique par exemple ces
20 heures vous avez vous avez un
organisme de formation qui voulez vous
qu'ils vous qui vous donne la formation
et vous avez un financement par votre
opca de ces 20 heures en moyenne c'est
un peu plus de 20 euros
leurs deux formations mais ça disent pas
c'est très disparate selon les
organismes de formation est là pour
réguler un peu les oreilles des
formations aux dires il transforme
honneur mais sauf que le salarié dans un
premier temps avant qu'on fasse un peu
le ménage dans les organismes de
formation qu'on est bien le salarié
avoir cessé 500 euros et est-ce que ça
suffira pour financer les formations
dont il a besoin
personne ne le sait pour l'instant donc
moi je ne veux pas que cette
transformation d'heure en euros je ne
veux pas que ce soit un affaiblissement
du droit des trois des travailleurs mc
c'est ça qui me rend l'ascension de
l'utiliser c'est pourquoi ce choix des
gouvernements été fait ce choix il faut
pas dire que la formation 5 milliards
d'euros oui et c'est dénoncer souvent
comme un gaspillage dans bien des cas il
ya beaucoup de fraudes aussi et frau ces
formations inaboutie mal conçu ce que
c'est une absence de régulation
donc là il ya une volonté de régulation
tant mieux tant mieux mais elle ne doit
pas se faire au détriment du droit des
salariés
c'est 12% des entreprises industrielles
aujourd'hui disent qu'ils ont un
problème pour répondre à leurs besoins
de commandes et n'arrive pas à fournir
parce que ils n'ont pas les compétences
nécessaires
l'enjeu de compétitivité demain la
compétitivité on en parle souvent
l'enjeu de compétitivité majeur demain
c'est la question
formation et les compétences des
travailleurs et donc on a besoin d'avoir
un système de formation beaucoup plus
pertinent tant mieux si la régulation
dans les organismes de formation
mais ne faisons pas reposer ça sur les
travailleurs en minorant leurs droits
c'est ça que je crains donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai demandé à la ministre a du
travail de préciser la façon dont va
certifier les organismes de formation et
on va opérer de façon paritaire sur le
nageur dans cette réforme il ya une
individualisation des choix de
formations gros plus de possibilité
donnée à chaque salarié de de faire le
choix de ces formations est de celles
qui pensent corresponde le mieux à ses
besoins d'amélioration de ses
compétences ou d'évolution de carrière
est ce que cette réforme là est ce
qu'elle va dans le bon sens considérant
que par rapport aux différentes voies la
réforme de la formation professionnelle
de ces dernières années 2004-2009 2014
on a une efficacité française une
inadéquation des formations aux besoins
en mai 2014
c'était les prémices de cette réforme
c'était déjà une division des droits et
donc moi je crois que c'est bien de
rendre les salariés acteurs de leur
parcours professionnel et qui puisse
regarder les formations qui les
intéressent qui ceux qui peuvent
répondre à leurs besoins
il faut que ça se fasse aussi en termes
de recensement des compétences
nécessaires dans les bassins d'emploi et
dans les branches professionnelles
parce que sinon on n'arrivera pas à
refaire cette adéquation entre les
besoins en emplois et les compétences
disponibles
donc il faut un accompagnement moi je ne
crois pas à l'individualisation je crois
pas que la division des droits
ce soit vous laisser tout seul dans la
pampa et à vous débrouiller je crois
qu'un certain nombre de salariés ont
besoin d'être accompagnés et dans cet
accord nous avons obtenu un droit à
l'accompagnement gratuit pour les
salariés qui en ferait la demande
cette fin le conseil s'est en évolution
professionnelle avait justement laurent
berger vous avez interpellé il ya
quelques minutes la ministre du travail
mme muriel pénicaud vous vous attendez
des réassurances sur les droits des
salariés elle elle nous interpelle
en fait vous allez voir elle vous flatte
plutôt sur ce conseil en évolution
professionnelle alors dans l'accord des
partenaires sociaux que vous avez signé
il ya une avancée très forte c'est
rendre le conseil en évolution
professionnelle
un réel droit très concret et gratuit
pour les salariés pour les demandeurs
d'emploi qui en ont besoin qui
souhaitent accompagner dans leurs choix
j'ai une question comment vous voyez ce
développement important et comment
réussir cette évolution cette révolution
du conseil en évolution professionnelle
qui est une des garanties de la qualité
de tout ce qu'on fera pour les salariés
pour les demandeurs d'emploi et pour les
entreprises c'est moi qui ai sur moi
vous savez j'étais conseiller en
insertion professionnelle
j'accompagnais des gens des personnes
qui étaient au rmi à l'époque et qui
cherchait un travail j'ai je me suis
aperçu à ce moment là que les bonnes
volontés la bonne volonté existe et
l'immense majorité des cas et il y avait
besoin d'un coup de pouce et besoin
d'orienter en disant qu'il ya tel ou tel
besoin j'ai encore rencontré il n'y a
pas si longtemps que ça
unsa une salariée qui parce que on avait
regardé les possibilités de formation
pour les aides soignantes à était avait
été aujourd'hui est soyons il faut ça se
dire quelles seront les opérateurs de ce
conseil en évolution professionnelle
par exemple il ya des compétences
aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on appelle les
fongecif des salariés qui sont
compétents pour accompagner les salariés
les salariés n'ont d'ailleurs en
fonction des besoins dans le territoire
des besoins dans les branches
professionnelles pour leur dire voilà là
il ya des possibilités
et selon ce qu est votre parcours
professionnel vous pouvez et bien
répondre à cette formation ça il va
falloir l'organiser retrouvez les
trouver les opérateurs pour le faire et
m informer les salariés qu'ils ont ce
droit aujourd'hui et si on veut mettre
l'application dont parle la ministre la
ministre parle d'une application sur un
smartphone vous pourrez faire valoir vos
droits
il faut tout de suite alerté les
travailleurs dix ans vous pouvez vous
faire accompagner par un professionnel
pour une agglo arrive au droit très bien
moi j'aimerais comprendre quand même
globalement est ce que c'est une bonne
réforme ou une mauvaise réforme c'est
une bonne réforme sur les droits des
travailleurs
parce que c'est des avancées très
concrète très substantiel même et c'est
dans la transformation de la gouvernance
du système de formation une une alerte
que je fais au gouvernement attention à
pas des branches et des tuyaux et en
revanche et d'autre ça va nous prendre
des années et des années et ça risque de
rendre le
l'utilisation des droits moins
pertinente donc moi vous vous
interrogiez est ce que vous êtes en
colère en colère je suis préoccupé je
suis à la fois satisfait qu'il ya des
droits des travailleurs plus pertinents
plus plus conséquent sur la formation
professionnelle et je suis préoccupé que
ces transformations que le la ministre
afin sans nous en avoir tellement alerté
en amont puisque elle peut pas dire que
les partenaires sociaux n'ont pas voulu
faire cette réforme sur la gouvernance
ne nous a pas tellement sollicité dans
la lettre de cadrage ou alain le sujet
et bien je suis préoccupé parce qu'il
faut pas on fera pas sans les branches
professionnelles
on fera pas sans les partenaires sociaux
on fera pas sur les organisations
syndicales sur les dans les territoires
pour savoir où sont les contenus sont
les besoins de compétences et comment y
répondre donc il faudra travailler
ensemble et à partenaires sociaux c'est
inventer un nouveau mode de gouvernance
voilà moi je demande à rencontrer très
vite la ministre du travail pour qu'on
se mette d'accord sur comment ça va
fonctionner est ce que justement on ne
va pas vers quelque chose vers un
pilotage plus efficace avec cet
organisme qu'il a chapeauté la la
formation professionnelle qui
s'appellera france compétences et qui
réunira états partenaires sociaux région
alors que là on a une gouvernance qui
est très éclaté mais justement peut-être
mais vous savez dans l'accord qu'on
avait qu'on a signé on prévoyait déjà de
réunir un certain nombre de tests
d'instance regarder le combat n'est fait
le fpspp c'est un peu techno mais
décimée
c'était pour dire qu'on avait déjà
commencé à opérer ça vous savez je suis
prêt à revenir devant vous prendre cet
engagement que si dans un an deux ans ça
fonctionne beaucoup mieux
j'aimerais me réjouir d'accord mais
alors réjouir que quels seront les
critères pour savoir si ça fonctionne
mieux
ce seront est-ce que ça répond aux
besoins en compétences des entreprises
est-ce que ça besoin ça répond aux
aspirations des travailleurs est ce que
les deux paires colle donc s'essayer à
voir je demande à voir
et pour ça je demande à ce qu'on joue
pas trop aux apprentis sorciers parce
que c'est bien d'annoncés de réformes
c'est plus difficile de la mettre en
place alors vous demander un rendez-vous
à la ministre du travail vous venez de
le dire mais ce que vous en demandez un
également à emmanuel macron parce que on
a l'impression que la marque de la cfdt
c'est à dire la démocratie sociale est
un peu bousculé dans ce moment en tous
les cas ce qui vous fâchent peut-être
est-ce que ce n'est pas contradictoire
avec ces avancées que vous reconnaissez
sur l'assurance chômage
la formation professionnelle donc ma
question concerne le chef de l'état est
ce que vous allez vous espérer reprendre
un dialogue fécond avec lui alors que
vous étiez l'interlocuteur privilégié du
précédent quinquennat ça n'est plus le
sahara c'est une formule le ce qui est
sure il le sait le lendemain de son
élection je lui fais une lettre ouverte
au près dans la république en disant
partager le pouvoir
aujourd'hui c'est clair que ce
gouvernement il est à la croisée des
chemins et ces exécutifs il a croisée
des chemins
est ce que dans cette volonté de
transformation du pays qu'on peut pas
lui signé il veut faire en concertant en
négociant en discutant avec les corps
intermédiaires n'est pas simplement les
organisations syndicales les injecteurs
l'aprona la photo où est ce qu'il veut
faire ça
si le faire sans je le dis ça court à
l'échec oui monsieur khadir est
d'ailleurs ce matin le délégué norman
sylla dit qu'ils avaient un pouvoir
politique desserte le dialogue social il
a dit que les stades castaner mais il ya
également un pouvoir politique qui a été
élu et qui a toute légitimité pour
changer l'italie
on a eu un premier ministre à un moment
donné en italie qui monsieur lorenzi
justement j'en parlais qui a dit
j'arrive et vous allez voir ça va
transformer je vais faire mon job act je
vais faire tout un tas de réforme une
par mois et vous allez voir par la seule
volonté politique par ma légitimité
politique je veux le faire
il s'est cassé la figure excusez moi de
vous dire il s'est cassé la figure parce
qu'il n'ya pas de transformation de la
société
si on n'emmène pas les corps
intermédiaires avec si on entraîne pas
derrière et qui a cette capacité là ce
sont les seuls corps intermédiaires donc
moi j'entends cette légitimité politique
là des mots clés je crois qu'il ya aussi
l'exercice de la démocratie sociale et
c'est pas une concurrence c'est une
imbrication des deux et je le dis il
faut écouter les corps intermédiaires
vaincrons c'est vrai dans l'agriculture
alors parlé avec les responsables
agricoles partout on a le sentiment
qu'il ya une forme de défiance à l'égard
des corps intermédiaires et bien si
cette défiance devait être un mode de
gouvernement
je le dis ça ira à l'échec mais vous lui
dites on lui dit au président de la vie
juridique vous lui dites angélique et
l'attention de survie nous sommes le
gage de votre réussite
non nous sommes surtout le gage que d'un
pays ne sombre pas dans ses vieux démons
non pas que ce qui a fait les syndicats
étaient les raisons qu'on était les
résultats excusez moi les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle
ça n'a pas disparu ce café le thé aux
gones le front national soit second tour
d'élection présidentielle
cela n'a pas disparu dans le pays et si
on veut pas que ça ressurgissent on n'a
pas de nom n'a pas intérêt à ce casse
est-ce que ça se plante je suis clair là
dessus mais ça peut pas réussir si on
fait pas de politique sociale assumer et
si on fait son décorateur vous allez
dites vous même que les syndicats
étaient mortelles comme les preuves
s'ils étaient mortels est ce que est ce
que vous ne souffrez pas quand même dans
un désamour général non mais moi les
amours s'éviter va pas dire je vais pas
vous dire là on est bientôt le 31 mars
31 mars et le 1er à la date anniversaire
où la cfdt est passé première
organisation syndicale
moi je chante pas de désamour de la part
des travailleurs d'ailleurs il ya une
enquête je crois qu'il va apparaître
bientôt sur les corps intermédiaires l
attachement des français à ces corps
intermédiaires mais je je je je je
constate qu'on doit tous évolué mais que
c'est pas la cvt qu'il faut dire que moi
j'ai pas de leçon de l'information
sociale à recevoir je n'ai pas de leçon
de réformisme prix doit recevoir donc
fait emmanuel ce que je demande c'est
que si on veut transformer il faut
discuter avec les différentes parties
prenantes de la société que sont les
corps intermédiaires sinon ça ne
marchera pas aller la deuxième grande
question ce soir de l'épreuve de vérité
et on va parler de la sncf c'est jean
francis qui va vous poser cette question
dans deux secondes
[Musique]
enfin fait flat la réforme de la sncf
est ce que vous allez tenter de nous
refaire le coup de 95 est ce que vous
allez bloquer ou au moins essayer de
bloquer le pays mais vous voyez que le
sujet est pas celui là sur la sncf sur
la sncf c'est comment on fait en sorte
que cette entreprise elle puisse
fonctionner correctement au bénéfice des
usagers et comment on fait en sorte que
le transforme le l'utilisation du rail
est un vrai levier de la transformation
écologique nécessaire à notre pays est
aujourd'hui on a une entreprise qui est
en difficulté et il y à de nouvelles
règles d'ouverture à la concurrence qui
la percute et donc la question est posée
de l'avenir du ferroviaire
on te voit qu'il est difficile à la
suite de tout un tas de choix politiques
y compris parfois des du politique qui
voulaient leur ligne tgv est qui affecte
qui ont fait que on délaisse un peu les
intégrer les autres lignes des petites
lignes et notamment les lignes en
banlieue qui souffrent beaucoup et donc
il ya une politique d'investissement à
mener et une politique de de dettes
il ya la question de la dette et il ya
la question qui est posée le monde est
d'accord la question portait sur l'amour
et non mais attendez moi je veux pas me
laisser enfermer dans ce style de
logique
j'ai pas me laisser enfermer en disant
est ce qu'on va refaire le coup de 95
vous savez 95 ça fait longtemps
donc c'est pas les mêmes les mêmes
levier ce que je dis c'est qu'on n'a pas
intérêt
quand on veut réformer le ferroviaire
d'un pays quand on veut consolider la
sncf
on n'a pas intérêt à dire que si il ya
des problèmes à montparnasse un certain
dimanche s'il ya des problèmes tous les
jours sur les lignes 2 les petites
lignes
c'est pas de la faute du statut des
cheminots c'est pas de la faute du
statut du cheminot est ce que ça veut
dire que le statut des cheminots est
immuable et qu'on peut pas discuter d'un
certain nombre d'évolutions nécessaires
y compris pour les sortir de situations
qui sont pas privilégiées tant qu'on
veut bien le dire aujourd'hui
avant qu'elle a raison si oui quels sont
les éléments du statut qui pénalise les
salariés de la essaie de faire et vous
savez par exemple est-ce que vous avez
une complémentaire santé payé par votre
employeur
oui c'est pas le cas des cheminots c'est
pas le cas des cheminots voilà j'ai un
exemple parmi d'autres donc je le dis
très franchement moi je ne ferais pas et
cheminot les coupables de la situation
de la sncf ou de la situation du rail
dans notre pays mais donc maintenant il
faut tuer s'il faut avoir vous allez
bien entendu ces faits car des vous avez
bien entendu monsieur pécresse les
organisations syndicales
oui ils organisent syndicales elles ont
dit qu'elles voulaient discuter il ya
une concertation ouverte par la ministre
des transports que je sais loyal cette
mini de transport et donc il faut que
ces concertations et lieux et décideront
ensuite sorti tous les syndicats sont
sortis des cieux la semaine dernière de
la première séance de concerts oui parce
que ça donnait son gréement concertation
est ce que le gouvernement
lefebvre et les organisations syndicales
elles ont décidé de s'y inscrire en tout
cas la cfdt cheminots a décidé de s'y
inscrire jusqu'au bout et encore des
réunions cette semaine nous allons y
participer sur cette réforme qu'est ce
qui vous choque le plus au fond est ce
que c'est le fond ou est ce que c'est la
forme est ce que c'est la méthode le
recours aux ordonnances parce que sur le
statut vous dit vous êtes la quatrième
organisation de la sncf mais au fond
vous n'êtes pas tout à fait hostile à ce
qu'ils aiment d'évolution de ce statut
le fond la forme la forme a été
extrêmement est extrêmement maladroite
vous savez on nous fait les ordonnances
moi je l'avais dit à l'été dernier
lorsque ça a été annoncé dans la
campagne il ya un président élu
il avait dit qu'il ferait par ordonnance
il le fait par ordonnance c'est la
démocratie
la sap a été annoncé précédemment ça a
été annoncé très tardivement que sa
lettre par ordonnance d'ailleurs la
rapidité du processus par ordonnance ça
mérite des discuter la réforme du marché
du travail
on est bien juste détachées et
finalement donc ça ne va pas si vite que
ça aussi aussi vite qu'on veut bien le
dire
donc là oui ça a choqué les cheminots et
je peux le comprendre parce que en plus
cons qu'on puisse discuter du volet
réforme ferroviaire ouverture à la
concurrence
par ordonnance bon ça se discute qu'on
puisse discuter du volet gouvernance de
la sncf par ordonnance ça se discute
mais le statut social des cheminots ils
discutent dans l'entreprise dans la
branche n'a pas besoin ordonnance n'a
pas besoin de revenir sur ce sujet là
ces ne s'est pas du tout justifiée donc
c'est ça qui a choqué aussi la cfdt
cheminots et que je partage
alors dans quelle surprise il faut
distinguer les deux les trois sujets il
ya un sujet investissement il ya un
sujet dans le ferroviaire est un sujet
gouvernance de la sncf
il est posée parce qu'en plus il ya
l'ouverture à la concurrence et
un sujet vous souhaitez social dans ce
cas prononce non mais c'est de croire au
père noël il ya un petit moment donc
c'est pas le sujet mais je dis que ça
ils peuvent traiter une grève dure mais
je crois que vous avez vocation syndical
s'est pas de se dire à quel moment je
vais pouvoir montrer les muscles pour
faire marcher là pour faire machine
arrière faire faire machine arrière
gouvernement fort aussi ça si bien sûr à
la force qui s'opère dans la discussion
et puis ensuite la dent dans d'autres
formes rapport de force que pouvait être
la manifestation houle ou la grève mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que moi je le dis
très clairement
discutons de la réforme ferroviaire et
d'ouverture à la concurrence de la
situation de la sncf et du rachat de la
dette pas enfin de 0,2 du et à l'état
donnez moi une autre solution
y'en a pas la dette elle est la
responsabilité ni les usagers ni des
cheminots faut qu'on soit clair là
dessus elle est la responsabilité de
mauvais choix qui ont été faits au fil
des décennies sur la sncf donc discuter
de ça et puis les sons les entreprises
c'est pas à l'état de le faire bien
votre entreprise discuter du statut des
cheminots et et à la branche aussi parce
qu'il va avoir des cheminots qui seront
publiés cncf seulement avec l'ouverture
à concurrence de le faire pas là
quelques s'est présentée c'est avec
c'est l'état qui en discuter oui mais je
crois que c'est d'erreurs mais m'a
clairement je crois qu'il y à des
responsables à la sncf
ddd des patrons à la sncf des
responsables ressources humaines à et 7e
acquise on discute mais ça c'est avec
tout cet cette réforme du statut ça
s'est fait à la poste à se coucher chez
orange essaie d entreprise qui se porte
plutôt mieux maintenant qu'elle ne se
portaient avant est ce que est ce que la
sncf peut échapper à ce mouvement qui
lui permettra de faire qui nous
permettrait de faire ce que je vous ai
donné le sentiment de pas vous de dire
que tout était immuable
je ne dis pas que tout des imams moi
j'entends avait boudé par la grippe a et
vous dites qu'ils ont peut aménager le
statut mais vous
on peut le supposer que normalement mais
mais mais il faut dire ce qu'on veut ou
les quoi emballer suis nommé question
précarisés comme en angleterre mais vous
voulez des cheminots auraient agi vous
voulez des cheminots contre à vouvry
baptisation du rail qui fait vous savez
qui fait en angleterre une sécurité
moindre
il n'est pas question de fiabilité
baptisé encore moins moi c'est pas bien
mais tentera t elle attendait en effet
habilitée moindre et à tarif mais a
donné il ya de la grande-bretagne ou la
privatisation du rail donne de bons
résultats mais on peut comparer les prix
mais personne n'a parlé y compris vous
aller un peu plus loin que le
gouvernement personne n'a parlé de la
privatisation c'est évitable
ces moines investisseurs pour une
entreprise qui à ce niveau la dette
je suis pas sûr de vous le trouver mais
en plus ça n'a pas de sens passez un
service public
moi je vous le dis je suis à ma tâche
est un service public du ferroviaire
est ce que l'art et les fonds des
nouveaux opérateurs privés ils sont déjà
sur les rangs pour transporter des
voyageurs un cerveau a déraillé sourire
ah oui vous inquiète
eh bien il faudra discuter de la
situation des cheminots qui seraient
concernés et la cfdt cheminots et est
ouverte à la discussion en se disant
quel sera le statut la situation sociale
des cheminots qui parce que leur ligne
sera dans le cadre de l'ouverture à la
concurrence
exploité par un autre une autre
entreprise que la sncf quelle sera leur
situation et quel sera leur libre choix
ou non dit d'y aller alors on va écouter
harcèlement et à la mobilisation à une
forte mobilisation
mais le 22 mars vous avez vu ou que la
confédération cfdt appelaient à une
manifestation où âme à la cgt appelle ça
vous a pas échappé
oui le décret si vous a pas échappé
depuis un an classé le dt devenue la
première organisation syndicale
il vous a pas échappé depuis quelques
années que la cfdt ne se demande pas ce
que font telle ou telle organisation
pour savoir ce qu'elle a à faire
elle même le 22 mars moi j'ai vu il y à
des appels
vous n'avez leur est permis au festival
il y à des appels successifs sur tout un
tas de sujets et au final y en a même un
aujourd'hui sur la réforme de la
formation professionnelle
en gros ça devient une manifestation en
tout et pour tout moi je préfère des
manifestations ciblées par exemple le 15
mars on va manifester sur la situation
dans les ehpad situation dramatique
on va en parler plus tard dramatique
pour les usagers dramatique pour les str
les professionnels je préfère aller soit
des objectifs ciblés pour faire aboutir
des évolutions concrètes pour les
travailleurs 22 mars vers et aux dalles
22 mars on verra si par exemple la sncf
sur un conflit cibler les cheminots à la
grève mais à la mode et à la
manifestation
pour l'instant ils ont dit qu'ils se
revoyaient le 15 mars était dans le
courant mars a interpellé l'état a par
le biais des préfets va interpeller les
parlementaires sur la situation dans les
fonctions publiques et le besoin de
dialogue social dans la fonction
publique et de moyens dans les fonctions
publiques
nous allons faire par différents moyens
notamment en rendant public beaucoup
plus largement un livre que nous avons
fait qu'est parole d'agents publics
s'appelle l'autre trésor public qui
montre combien les fonctionnaires sont
pas un coût mais sont une richesse pour
notre pays pour notre cohésion sociale
on parlera de leurs indices dans un
instant je voulais vous faire écouter et
engagé bernard vivier et que vous
connaissez bien grand spécialiste des
partenaires sociaux et voilà comment lui
il voit en tous les cas le scénario de
la réforme engagées à la sncf banc en un
mot inévitable cette réforme va se faire
et les syndicats en sont conscients à
partir de là quelle est leur position ou
bien défendre absolument le statut des
cheminots mais ils n'ont pas l'opinion
publique pour eux ou bien négocié les
évolutions et même tenté de faire de
cette négociation de cette concertation
sur la sncf une contrepartie à d'autres
négociations plus difficiles
assurance chômage et formation
professionnelle alors on parle souvent
du gagnant de l'élection là que serait
donnant donnant c'est un mélange pas les
choux et les carottes les tomates sous
faut faire de la soupe je veux pas faire
de souci donc c'est vous il ya un truc
il faut comprendre un cfdt allait pas
dans le deal elle n'est pas dans les
îles
elle est pas dans l est dans la
discussion et le compromis au service
des travailleurs et de l'intérêt général
et donc moi je n'aurais pas échangé une
position modérée sur tel sujet contre
tel ou trop de sujets j'ai pris le sujet
de l'assurance chômage
le sujet de la formation professionnelle
et on les traite en propre et en dehors
notre appréciation ont su on a ensuite
on va discuter de la sncf c'est pas la
cfdt la confédération qui le fait c'est
la branche professionnelle et ce comme
on le fait comme aujourd'hui on est en
discussion dans telle ou telle
entreprise privée un carrefour ou
ailleurs quand il ya des difficultés ou
quand il ya des opportunités puisqu'il
ya aussi fariz entreprises font plutôt
une opportunité quand risque alors tous
les cas la sncf était au coeur de notre
sondage de la semaine
opinionway réalisé pour l'épreuve de
vérité première question une grève des
cheminots sort est elle justifiée à vos
yeux
non à 58 % mais quand même 40 % de oui à
ce stade un mot je crois je crois que
les français ils n'ont pas tellement
envie qu'on ce qu'ont les dresse les uns
contre les autres et je crois que comme
nos deux pays étant mal les politiques
sociales vraiment assumé on en parlera
peut-être un peu plus tard
oui et bien des français ils sont
sensibles à ce qui peut leur paraître
injuste et donc si on continue moi je ne
suis pas sûr que le gouvernement ait
intérêt à monter un front anti cheminots
contre un front syndical très radicale
qui faire bloc contre bloc je crois pas
que ce soit une bonne une bonne idée est
ce votre sondage finalement alors il dit
à vanessa
deuxième question c'était sur
l'utilisation des ordonnances pour les
réformes et là on voit que en fait les
réponses entre les favorable et
favorable c'est à égalité à 49% n'a pas
de position de la grille et parce que je
crois que je crois que les ordonnances
là en tout cas pour ceux pour cette
cette fois ci sur les cheminots ça donne
le sentiment et la scène serré ça donne
le sentiment qu'on va aller très vite et
et quand on va aller très vite parfois
les français ils ont sentiment qu'il ya
un loup mais je le rappelle les
ordonnances
c'est pas l'absence de discussions et de
débats et puis surtout savait passer à
l'as pas si vite que ça parce que là on
est déjà au mois de mars et on vient
juste d'avoir finalement la fin des
ordonnances de viol est qui qui se met
en place
alors troisième partie de l'émission
maintenant nous allons évoquer bien vos
revendications
suite à l'embellie économique que l'on
constate avec bonheur depuis quelques
mois et c'est du cil malandain qui vous
pose cette question alors la croissance
est revenue à 2% dès cette année comment
selon vous en répartir les fruits alors
que de plus en plus de salariés
air france le transport routier les
autoroutes réclament leur part de
redistribution dans d'abord moi je me
réjouis de la croissance ça peut
paraître bizarre pour un syndicalisme et
mais j'ai toujours dit je les dis depuis
longtemps que ce qui m'intéressait plus
tôt que le chiffres d'évolution de la
croissance était le contenu de cette
croissance est ce que l est comme on dit
en europe inclusive c'est à dire qu'est
ce qu'elle permet de réduire les
inégalités de réduire les situations de
pauvreté et de répartir mieux c'est les
fruits de cette croissance et donc oui
et la question elle est posée
aujourd'hui elle est posée dans les
entreprises qui ont le voit avons mieux
que la richesse créée c'est normal
qu'ils soient répartis dans des
politiques salariales avec des
augmentations de salaires des primes
parfois comme ce ps ah bah oui
l'intéressement de la participation
c'est tout à fait normal
je vous rappelle que une entreprise
c'est le capital et c'est le travail et
que le travail il doit aussi être
rémunéré à un bon niveau
donc il ya ce sujet là dans le retour de
cette croissance qui est posée
entreprise par entreprise ou secteur
d'activité par secteur d'activité et
puis plus globalement dans notre pays et
à la façon dont on mène des politiques
sociales
claire assumer pour
réduire les inégalités vous savez j'ai
été avec un ambassadeur je vous dirai
pas de quel pays tout à l'heure qui me
disaient qu'ils circulent pas mal dans
notre pays et qu'il est frappé par le
décrochage d'un certain nombre de deux
citoyens dans les villes moyennes dans
les zones rurales dans les cités dans
les banlieues et je fais le même constat
et moi je fais le même constat à travers
nos militants qui nous disent mais nous
on le voit passer on l'a on la voit pas
cette croissance elle n'est pas
perceptible pour nous on a toujours ce
sentiment d'être resté un peu au bord du
chemin et vous savez le risque dans ces
de ces périodes où la croissance repart
c'est que le train accélère d'une
certaine manière mais si vous n'êtes pas
dedans vous loyer partir plus vite c'est
tout mais ça n'a pas de conséquence
concrète sur votre vie et donc moi je
dis le gouvernement doit mener des
politiques sociales assumées
il doit maintenant donner des signaux
sociaux très fort lequel parisien les
calmer eh bien ça veut dire en direction
des citoyens les plus fragiles les plus
pauvres je crois qu'il ya un plan de
pauvres un plan pauvre du lait qui
célèbrent dans la rue à destination des
enfants et des jeunes mais il faut aussi
que les familles soient soient
accompagnés pour sortir de la pauvreté à
l'égard des jeunes qualifiés qui
trouvent pas de travail aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils sont discriminés et c'est
une réalité très forte et il ya un plan
aussi à des discussions autour de
monsieur borloo qui se font aujourd'hui
la cfdt est très impliquée dans ces
discussions
il faut des politiques dans les
fonctions publiques pour que on arrête
cette désertification dans l'est dans un
certain nombre de territoires où les
services publics
finalement ne sont plus présents et
donne le sentiment d'un abandon aux
citoyens enfin tout ce qui a fait qu'à
un moment donné marine le pen a été au
second tour d'élection présidentielle et
le gouvernement il doit écouter ce
mal-être aujourd'hui sinon oui il va à
sa perte mais là vous êtes en train de
nous parler de distribution d'argent
public
or ce qui ce qui se joue dans les
entreprises c'est la négociation c'est
des négociations pour redistribuer des
fruits de la croissance privé est ce
qu'on n'est pas en train de confondre
deux noms parce que vous savez quand il
ya de la croissance privé il faut
qu'elle participe à la croissance public
ça me parait c'est ce qu'on appelle la
mutualisation c'est ce qu'on appelle la
fiscalité mais là le gouvernement a
donné la priorité à la réduction de la
dette
oui mais justement vous savez
l'italie va nous le rappeler durement
les citoyens ils sont pas omnibulé par
le chiffre de 3%
il est important la cfdt vous le savez
depuis longtemps a dit que transmettent
une des tâches générations futures
étaient extrêmement dangereux et je
continue de porter cette exigence mais
ça peut pas être le seul horizon
ça peut pas être le seul horizon il faut
on le voit en italie on le voit ailleurs
en europe
à chaque fois que la question sociale a
été délaissé on a donné sentiment qu'il
fallait d'abord faire des efforts
d'abord relancer l'économie sans que
tout le monde puisse en bénéficier
eh bien on va vers des crises
démocratique et on va vers une société
société qui se fracturent et moi je ne
veux pas ça et on est au bord de cette
fois question simple par exemple est ce
que vous êtes pour une revalorisation du
smic pour un desserrement delà de la
règle d'indexation du smic si je suis
pour que l'exposé là je suis pour que
alex à sion du smic continue de se faire
sur telle qu'elle se fait aujourd'hui
gelée j'ai été très clair lorsque le
rapport des experts est sorti et parce
que le smic c'est le salaire minimum le
seul problème du smic vous savez c'est
quoi c'est pas qu'il existait à nier
c'est que il grignote tout un toutou les
bacs gris comme audi dans les groupes
dans les conventions collectives parce
que il n'ya pas de politique de carrière
et de rémunération digne de ce nom d'un
certain nombre de branches
professionnelles
donc je suis moi j'ai pas d'état d'âme
là dessus lorsqu'une entreprise et gagne
de l'argent elle doit redistribuer une
partie de cet argent évidemment vers
l'investissement
évidemment vers les actionnaires mais
évidemment dans les travailleurs et
quand les recettes fiscales augmentent
et il faut qu'il manque le point
d'indicé par exemple quand il meurt en
tout cas faut pas qu'il fasse des
fonctionnaires simplement eu un coût est
donc le point lundi si les budgets
depuis un certain nombre de denrées
étant surtout là ils seraient bien
inspirés gouvernement de mettre en
oeuvre les mesures prévues dans le plan
qui s'appelait carrière rémunération
rémunération qui avait été actée par le
précédent
la précédente le précédent gouvernement
pour qui prévoyait des évolutions de
carrière pour un certain nombre de
travailleurs je prends un exemple on
parle des ehpad on parle des hôpitaux
les aides soignants et aides soignantes
beaucoup et elles sont un des métiers
aujourd'hui les plus difficiles où la
question y compris l'espérance de vie
est une des plus faibles
on a dans les écoles d'aides-soignants
une baisse des candidats extrêmement
inquiète
eh bien nous on revendique que les aides
soignantes et les aides soignants passe
de la catégorie c à la catégorie b
voilà des revendications très précises
qui permettrait une reconnaissance de
carrière de ces professionnels dont on a
tant besoin
on a parlé donc de la croissance privé
on a parlé de également du budget de
l'état et quand des fonds publics vont à
des entreprises qui finissent par fermer
ou et licencier leur personnel là vous
dites qu'il ya des choses à revoir je
pense notamment à l' usine ford près de
bordeaux à blanquefort 1 où le site est
menacé
il ya eu beaucoup de fonds publics
notamment régionaux parce que là vous
appeler à un changement s'appelle
surtout à ce que du coup ça donne une
légitimité aux acteurs publics à la
région en l'occurrence là mais aussi à
l'état d'intervenir en tout cas pour
exiger un traitement des travailleurs
digne en termes de maintien de l'emploi
mais aussi en termes de reclassement
lorsqu'il ya difficultés économiques
moi je suis pas pour l'économie dirigée
c'est une surprise pour personne mais je
suis pas non plus pour que les aides
publiques aux entreprises ne m'implique
pas un certain nombre de règles éthiques
morales et de responsabilité sociale et
environnementale
j'étais quand j'étais en pays de la
loire rapporteur d'un projet d'avis au
conseil économique social
environnemental qui était sur la
conditionnalité des aides publiques
moi je crois que les entreprises elles
sont elles doivent justifier de
l'utilité qu'elles ont l'utilisation
qu'elles ont des aides publiques qu'ils
sont versées aux entreprises et elles ne
font pas suffisamment
elles ne font pas suffisamment que ce
soit lorsqu'ils sont en situation
difficile où elles lorsqu'elles vont
bien en embauchant des apprentis en
ayant des politiques de formation de
respect de leurs sous traitants et donc
on peut avancer beaucoup plus loin vous
vous êtes réjouit il ya quelques
instants du retour de la croissance est
ce que vous vous réjouissez pareillement
du record de bénéfices des entreprises
du cac 40 95 milliards d'euros
non ça ça me touche beaucoup moins mais
vous savez ce dont je me sens quand on
peut lier des choses sont liées non oui
mais vous savez à condition qu'elle
s'interroge sur la façon dont elle
participe au bien commun à la chose
collective
moi je ne suis pas pour des entreprises
et un rapport qui va être rendue cette
semaine extrêmement important sur les
finalités de l'entreprise et et bien moi
je suis pour que l'entreprise est laid
et d'autres finalités que simplement la
rentabilité et le rendement à ses
actionnaires il faut qu'ils n' roll une
finalité
économie social et environnemental donc
moi vous savez je me réjouirais dans
notre pays
lorsque la croissance elle servira aussi
à réduire la pauvreté notamment la
pauvreté des enfants qui touche plus
d'un million d'enfants dans notre pays
lorsqu elle servira à réduire les
inégalités à réduire les discriminations
on en est encore très loin
donc c'est cela c'est à cela que cette
dynamique avec les bénéfices records pas
antinomiques
et ouais vous savez je suis pas vous
avez pu le remarquer bien sûr
l'opposition entre les missions et les
bons danseurs et les bons de l'autre
côté et je ne dis pas que c'est
antinomique
je dis qu'aujourd'hui c'est inégal
inégale on vit dans un pays qui est trop
inégal
alors qu'il a de la richesse et qui
pourrait réduire ces inégalités par des
choix collectifs
c'est ça que je dis maintenant tant
mieux si la croissance repart parce que
ça va permettre peut-être de le faire
encore faut-il des politiques sociales
assumées qui manque aujourd'hui vous
avez entendu les critiques sur emmanuel
macron président des riches
c'est un peu ce que vous nous dites là
donc je pousse et ça c'est une formule
vous allez venir ces délais sont vous
savez je sais je sais bien alors c'est
un slogan pour vous président des riches
n'ont en tout cas pour l'instant un
certain nombre de mesures qui ont été
prises depuis l'été les apl la baisse
des contrats aidés dont on voit qu'ils
aient un rapport sénatorial qui dit que
c'est une catastrophe pour les
territoires et les associations et pour
le chômage la question de certain nombre
d'augmentations des minima sociaux sauf
du rsa par exemple eh bien c'est la
démonstration que on n'a pas tout fait
loin s'en faut pour les cons pour les
personnes fragiles et pauvres dans le
pays
il est grand temps qu'on le fasse
d'accord et donc vous encourage emmanuel
macron à prendre les bonnes mesures pour
changer d'étiquette de slogans bah moi
je formule le dos je collerais jamais
des étiquettes ça m'intéresse pas mais
c'est quand même si on pouvait réduire
la pauvreté de façon extrêmement
importante
on aurait effet oeuvre utile on aurait
fait du rutile pour les personnes
concernées pour notre société pour
l'europe pour la démocratie pour pavie
ce qu'est en train de dire ça nous
ramène à la question des débuts sur la
poussée du populisme tout près de chez
nous merci beaucoup lamberger d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui merci à vous
merci à la semaine prochaine à tous
[Musique]
comment